Yeah, and I think he has a -
Tom, Tom.
- that he's using to ... anyway.
I love you, but everything you've described
is the stuff I read obsessively.
Hello.
So today we are going to talk about the DC
comic series that we most want to see turn
into a TV show.
I am here with Tom and Nina to talk about
this.
And my pick is a fairly obscure comic book
that I am 99% certain neither of you have
ever heard of, and it is called Major Bummer.
Anyone, anyone?
No, you're correct that I'm not familiar.
Now, the reason I'm sure of this is because
it was canceled after 15 issues.
Oh, okay.
It came out in 1997.
That tracks.
Yeah.
And it lasted for a little over a year, but
the pedigree is solid.
It was written by John Arcudi and penciled
by Doug Monk, who are the duo behind The Mask,
the original Mask comics that the movie was
based on.
Wow.
So they're real deal comic book big deal guys.
So these aliens are in college, and part of
their thesis project is to give random people
superpowers and see what happens, only they
research the people and they -
That's weird, I had the same thesis project.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
How'd you do?
Not great.
I think Nina and I just made the same face
the whole time that you were describing that.
Just very, very concerned, yeah.
It's a comedy.
It's not a serious comic book.
Yeah.
It is filled with jokes and gags and hilarity.
You're kidding?
No, I know it's hard to believe.
So one of the aliens who's sending out the
superpower machines doesn't realize that the
phone book lists names backwards, so sends
it to the wrong person.
This guy, this slacker, Lou Martin, gets super
powers and gets super duper buff.
And throughout the entire run of the comic
book series, which again, only lasts 15 issues,
he's basically completely uninterested in
doing anything heroic, anything at all.
There's a super team that wants him to join
and he's just like, "Yeah, no, thanks.
I would really rather play video games and
eat a sandwich."
So he's Ralph Bohner?
He's Ralph Bohner, exactly.
Don't speak that name in this house.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to bring up such an unpleasant memory
for you.
Major Bummer was 1997, and it's got very heavy
generation X vibes of what if a slacker got
super powers?
And I know that it's kind of a silly, lame
sounding logline, but at the end of the day,
giving irresponsible people superpowers is
probably one of the most used tropes in all
of these superhero movies and TV shows that
we actually really like.
So if they kind of committed to it and went
all in on it and just had a pretty decent
budget, it could be really, really fun.
I could dig that, yeah.
I think it would be really great.
I don't have any hope for it, because again,
15 issues, no one remembers it, but maybe
me.
And then beyond that, there's not a super
great track record for comic book shows and
movies ... comic book shows specifically that
are specifically humorous.
So The Tick, The Tick has had tons of TV shows
and they've all gotten canceled too early.
And The Tick is amazing.
I love The Tick.
And it's just one of those things where for
some reason you can have comedy in your superheroes,
but you can't have your superheroes be a comedy.
So that's my pick and I'm not holding out
any hope that it'll ever happen.
I like it though.
And I think you've -
I love it.
- sold it well, where it's -
Thank you, Tom.
Yeah, make it funny.
Have some levity about this.
I mean, that's why people like Marvel movies
in the first place, is because they had some
levity to them.
Have your hero never learn anything and never
want to learn anything.
Right.
That's the premise.
I love it.
And it's wonderful.
It's like if Dan Harmon wrote an MCU story.
No, it's got all the component parts of a
Dan Harmon movie.
It's got the flawed hero, just minus the learning.
If you got the right people involved, it could
be really amazing.
Yeah.
And you mentioned Dan Harmon, and there's
definitely a lot going on in Rick and Morty
that I think probably ... again, I don't think
it's a direct line, but I would say that maybe
it's in the air, maybe somehow the things
that influence Major Bummer also then went
on to influence Rick and Morty in the same
way.
Got you.
It just was ahead of its time.
It was a beautiful flower that nobody but
me decided to smell.
Years and years later ... my collection only
had issues two through 15 and years later,
I bought issue number one on eBay for a few
bucks.
And I was like, "Finally, it's mine!"
And meanwhile, it was an $8 purchase.
It's not rare, it's just that nobody -
Right.
No one cares.
But it's great.
Those were always my favorite comics.
I had every Alpha Flight, for whatever it's
worth.
You are weirdly obsessed with Alpha Flight.
You know what?
If you ever want to do a full, let's say three
and a half hour video essay on Alpha Flight,
I am there for it.
I'm a hundred percent down.
Can we put a little name tag under him that
says Tom, weirdly obsessed with Alpha Flight,
for the remainder of the video.
I'd like that very much.
Okay.
Now everyone knows.
Yeah.
They spelled my name wrong.
Nina, what's your pick for the DC comic story
that you want to see turn into a TV show?
I typically prefer Marvel because of the aforementioned levity and comedy that they go for,
moreso than DC.
I mean, Shazam was one of the more fun DC
movies.
I thought Birds of Prey was a lot of fun,
stuff like that.
But I also love the HBO adaptation.
I know Watchmen kind of ... Watchmen is DC,
yes?
Watchmen is DC, and now it's more DC than
it ever was.
Yeah.
Because for a long time -
I feel like ... yeah.
Yeah, for a long time it was separate and
apart from DC.
It was -
That's what I thought.
Brief Watchmen history lesson.
Yes, please.
All the Watchmen characters are based on Charlton
Comics characters that DC had acquired and
planned to use.
Alan Moore wanted -
He knows his stuff.
Alan Moore wanted to use all of these characters
and DC said, "No, we have plans for Blue Beetle.
Make him Night Owl instead," so he did.
This is why we pay you the big bucks, Brian.
I know some things.
So I loved the HBO adaptation of Watchmen,
as I suspect we all did, and pretty much everybody
did.
So I kind of went hunting for something else
that I thought could make a cool mini series
that was a little on the darker side.
And I came across the 1996 series written
by Mark Wade and Alex Ross called Kingdom
Come.
Are you two familiar?
Kingdom Come!
Yeah.
That's so good.
Oh, I'm so mad I didn't think of that.
That's real bleak.
I read a good portion of it.
It's also a beautiful comic.
Alex Ross, baby.
I know that you've both seen it, but I'm sending
a panel from it anyway.
It's just ... it was stunning to look at.
I kind of got really wrapped up in reading
it, to the detriment of my work, probably.
It felt very current as well, because The
Boys has been such a big hit as well, in kind
of examining the role of superheroes and whether
or not we can just blindly put our trust in
them or if they're taking advantage of the
public good will.
I would say that The Boys owes almost everything
to Kingdom Come.
Exactly.
So I think this would be a really good move
for DC to take.
The OG Justice League ... bring the same actors
back, that's fine.
And then cast that ragtag group of miscreants
who just run around murdering everybody.
So just to briefly recap what the premise
of Kingdom Come is, basically it's the future
and superheroes just don't care about kind
of collateral damage.
They're just super power beings and the fighting
all the time and they call themselves superheroes,
but they're mostly just super powered.
And they're led by Magog, who will just murder
with impunity.
And everyone's rallying behind him, which
the Justice League is like, "Why?
Why is this acceptable?"
Right, but most of the Justice League is retired
by this point.
Right.
I think Superman's living on a farm and Diana's
back ... yeah, she's back -
She's on.
Thank you for pronouncing it.
Yeah, so they've scattered to their ends of
the earth, and then this -
It's kind of this beautiful retirement story
for a bunch of, just existing too fast.
It also felt very kind of modern, even though
it was written in the nineties, where during
a fight with two superheroes, one of them
gets ... I believe it's Captain Atom gets
yanked apart and it gives the entire American
Midwest radiation poisoning.
Yeah.
Which is funny when you say it, and then it's
also so upsetting.
And that's the reason that they all leave,
right?
Right.
So yeah.
I mean Brian, you probably have much more
to explain about this than my ... I've read
about half the issues, but -
What's great about it is it's basically this
story of what does it mean to be a hero?
What does it mean to have power?
And it's Superman ... basically Batman kind
of wrangles Superman and other people out
of retirement, if I'm remembering all the
details correctly.
I believe that's correct, yeah.
And basically the idea is just kind of the
older heroes kind of coming after the newer
heroes to try to say, "Hey, stop it.
You can't do this.
You're tearing the world apart, and here's
why, and here's how."
It's such a pretty story.
We got Shazam, Captain Marvel ... back when
they could call him Captain Marvel still -
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- fighting Superman.
And that fight scene is honestly one of the
most exciting.
It's so ... you haven't gotten there yet,
Nina.
The way they drew that.
You got to get to the end.
You got to finish this thing.
It's so good.
Yeah, I'm going to.
Oh my God, what a pick.
You know what I'm going to do after the call
today?
I'm going to read Kingdom Come.
It sounds super exciting.
I love it.
I've inspired you.
It's such a great story.
Yeah.
It's such a great pick.
And I just think on a network like HBO, that
could give it a budget and a really good director,
it could be amazing.
It would be amazing.
And I feel like HBO is the perfect place,
because I feel like they wouldn't over-bloat
the story and make it and be 13 or 14 episodes.
They'd let it be five, maybe six.
But yeah, I want a dark Kingdom Come adaptation.
Yeah.
But it's ultimately a story of hope.
Exactly.
And that's the thing.
Yeah.
Because it's all about the value of having
values.
Oh, I feel like such a cheesy corny loser,
but yeah.
No, and the problem is I just want Damon Lindelof
to direct it too, but I also understand he
can't do everything.
He can't do everything, but he's definitely
proven himself with Watchmen.
When that Watchmen show was announced, I looked
at the trailer and I was like, "What?
Really?
Are you sure?"
Yeah.
Because I am not a big fan of the Watchmen
movie from our friend Zach Snyder.
I wasn't aware that anyone was, but yeah,
go on.
There are people who like that movie, and
I will not say that they are wrong to like
it.
You're right.
Everyone is allowed to feel that way.
I will say, it's not for me.
It's not for me.
And maybe some other day we'll talk about
why, but Damon Lindelof definitely did an
amazing job with Watchmen and he put all my
fears to rest.
So yeah, that's a great pick, Nina.
Thank you.
I impressed the comics king.
I'm retired.
It's a great idea.
Goodbye everyone.
Bye, Nina.
I'm going to George Costanza this.
I'm out.
Nina turned into star dust.
So Tom, what's your pick?
I present to you my pitch.
Consider for a moment the fact that by their
very nature, television adaptations ... and
keeping in mind that I love Watchmen.
I felt Watchmen was terribly impressive.
I also love a lot of the kind of lower budget,
really beautiful, brilliant TV adaptations
that we've seen in the last few years, like
Doom Patrol, I think is kind of gorgeous in
its own unique way.
There's some great DC television content out
there.
So I don't mean to disparage that.
However, television adaptations do come with
sort of a pre-established trashiness, right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Either visually, in terms of the special effects,
or in terms of the writing, sometimes both.
Can we agree on that?
Yes.
I agree.
That said, the last few years, television
has kind of shifted a little bit and turned
into, at least in some places, think pieces
and really clever narratives, like True Detective,
and like Watchmen, and overall, just these
things that I'm not smart enough to understand.
So I think that the best possible television
adaptation would be something that combines
these three things: terrible visuals, not
great writing, and I don't understand it,
which is why I think that the best TV DC adaptation
would be every comic that DC put out in the
nineties.
So I've got a whole list of stuff that would
work perfectly for that.
So you've got red and blue Superman, both
of them looking sort of like butt, and I still
don't get what happened.
Superman dies and half of the panels are just
dedicated to trying to advertise these new
characters that nobody cares about with names
that I don't even remember anymore.
Asriel taking over as Batman, Batman becomes
a French guy with too many spikes on his body.
Then we get whatever Eradicator was, because
I'm, again, still not clear on that.
Aquaman loses a hand and it gets it back and
we don't understand why.
Nightwing has a mullet and then he cuts it
off.
Parallax, Dr. Fate in the nineties ... I don't
know if you guys remember this, but Dr. Fate
all of a sudden abandoned the Hippocratic
Oath and just turned into this ... I don't
know if you've ever read Grimjack -
Serious accusation, Tom.
But he basically turned into Grimjack.
He's missing an eye and I think -
He has the ankh over his eye?
Yeah, and I think he has -
Tom -
- a knife that he's using to ... anyway.
I love you, but everything you've described
is the stuff I read obsessively, and I love
all of this and I can probably explain most
of it.
All right, well let's stop recording and then
Brian's going to make me feel bad about it.
No, I'm just saying -
If you don't understand something, you just
got to ask Brian.
I'm just saying ... okay, so I really like
this idea.
I really like the ... Superman red blue was
ridiculous.
It is a little hard to kind of work out what
exactly happened there, but it also was an
homage to a storyline from the fifties where
Superman red and Superman blue happen.
And also, another DC comic book from the nineties,
Kingdom Come.
Very true.
I was going to say.
And also -
1996.
- all these JLA comics right here, the Grant
Morrison JLAs that I love.
Yeah.
All these Starman comic books that are amazing.
Grant Morrison has always been kind of a ... what
do you call it, lighthouse in a foggy ocean.
But Starman was James Robinson.
I stand corrected.
I'm sorry, Tom.
No, I'm a fool.
All I'm saying is that ... did you guys watch
the Crisis on Infinite Earth special that
they did with the Arrow-verse about two years
ago?
I did not, but I'm aware of it.
Yeah, I've seen the name.
It feels like if Terry Gilliam had sneezed
that movie into existence, kind of accidentally.
It's rough.
It's real rough.
That's bone chilling.
And I feel like the quality of that mixed
with the kind of absence of consciousness,
I feel like that could've made a wonderful
television series.
Just nothing makes sense and everything looks
like crap.
Here's what I think is happening.
I think you're picking up on the fact that
DC comics, more than Marvel, has had a more
difficult relationship with it's continuity,
basically.
Yeah.
Sure.
In the late eighties, the Crisis on Infinite
Earth, the thing that you mentioned, was basically
... so way back in the forties, we have Superman,
we have Batman, we have The Flash, we have
Green Lantern, we have Wonder Woman.
We have all these characters, and then they
go away for a while.
And then in the late fifties ... I want to
say late fifties, early sixties, they bring
them back, a lot of them, but new versions
of them.
You've got a new Flash, you've got a new Green
Lantern, you've got Wonder Woman, but started
over.
You've got new versions of old characters
names like The Atom.
In the Golden Age, The Atom was just a short
guy, but in the Silver Age, he could actually
shrink.
Wait, is that real?
Yes.
Adam was just a small man?
He was just really small.
He had a blue mask that covered his whole
face and a cape and a weightlifting belt and
he just ran around punching Nazis and other
crooks and yegs and henchmen and things.
So what happens is over time, DC comics has
all of these different continuities that is
just confusing, so the Silver Age heroes are
these different versions of the Golden Age
heroes and they said, "How do we reconcile
this?
They live on parallel earths."
So eventually you have earth one, earth two,
earth X, earth ... I don't know, it just goes
on and on and on.
And then as DC comics acquires different comic
book characters, like Captain Marvel -
Captain Marvel.
- which was published by Faucet Comics.
And then all the Charlton Comics characters
that we talked about earlier that were going
to be the Watchmen characters, they were all
existing on separate earths.
So in order to clean it up and make it seem
a little bit more streamlined, they did Crisis
on Infinite Earth, a bunch of characters died,
and eventually they were just like, "Okay,
here's when everything started.
Everything's on the same earth.
This is how it happened."
So that was just a house cleaning exercise.
That's all it was.
And that's all it ever was.
But they kept doing it every ten years for
the rest of time.
They kept doing it, yes.
And that's the problem, because then in the
nineties they did Zero Hour, and then a bunch
of years later, they did the New 52, which
was when I ... shortly after the New 52, I
hopped off, because I just couldn't keep up
anymore.
But yeah, that's been more of DC's thing.
Marvel hasn't done that quite as much, but
they have been doing it too, because our favorite
character Miles Morales, he's an awesome addition
to the Spider-Man universe, he started out
as the second ultimate Spiderman on the ultimate
universe and then he got folded into the main
line Marvel universe during the recent ... I
want to say Secret War.
I think they recycled the old Secret War name.
I think it was, yeah.
I'm getting way off track here, but what you're
picking up on is the fact that in the nineties,
DC comics was very crazy and a lot of weird
stuff happened in an effort to try to do new
and interesting things.
And they kept throwing weird ideas out, like
the death of Superman, the new Batman, John
Paul.
John Paul, I don't remember ...
John Paul Valley was his name.
And he was Asriel and he became Batman.
I think I'm babbling.
Not at all.
No.
I think I mostly read comic books instead
of doing homework in high school.
And that's everything I've just -
Well, to Brian's teachers watching this, now
you know.
If Ms. from All Saints private school in the
fourth grade, I'm going to say about 1996
or circa at that point, ever sees this ... nevermind,
I don't have anything poetic to say.
Change my mind.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single video.